voluntarios italianos se apresuran a
instalar dos centros de acogida en
catania el puerto oriental de la isla de
sicilia se prepara para acoger a unas
700 personas que necesitan asistencia
scarpe
a los supervivientes les damos zapatos y
mantas luego ofrecemos comidas calientes
proponemos actividades recreativas
especialmente para los niños para
intentar distraerlos y relajarlos
esperemos que no tengan que esperar
demasiado tiempo en el mar
Los guardacostas italianos están
dirigiendo los esfuerzos para rescatar
al menos dos embarcaciones que se
encuentran en peligro en el Mediterráneo
esta embarcación que transportaba 400
personas se quedó sin combustible y
empezó a hacer agua el domingo cerca de
Malta desde enero Italia ha visto casi
cuatro veces más llegadas que en el
mismo periodo del año pasado con unas
31.000 personas alcanzando las costas
italianas muchas acaban en la pequeña
isla de la pelusa donde los refugios se
han visto desbordados
hay muchas mujeres con niños pequeños y
varios menores no acompañados estamos en
una situación de emergencia al personal
intenta hacer lo que puede para
responder a las necesidades más urgentes
de primaria el gobierno de derechas de
Italia ha declarado el estado de
emergencia durante seis meses permitirá
a Italia gestionar mejor las llegadas
pero también Identificar y expulsar más
rápidamente a quienes decidan que no
tienen derecho a quedarse